this video is made possible by nord VPN
start protecting your internet
experience today at Nord VPN comm
forward slash biographic stand use the
code by graphics to get 75% of a
three-year plan and also get a months
for free count Victor Lustig may indeed
be the most successful con man of the
20th century from the Belle Epoque to
the Great Depression through the roaring
20s and across two continents this
elegant swindler eluded the grasp of the
law while racking up hundreds of
thousands of dollars newspapers
described him as a storybook character
federal agent said of him that he was as
elusive as a puff of cigarette smoke and
as charming as a young girl's dream
today though we remember him as Victor
Lustig the man who sold the Eiffel Tower
[Music]
cam Victor Lustig was born on the fourth
of January 1819 to an aristocratic
austro-hungarian family his birthplace
was the town of Hostin a peg then part
of the province of Bohemia in modern-day
Czech Republic or at least that's one of
the stories that he told Victor Lustig
was born on the fourth of January 1890
the son of Ludvig de middle class
burgomaster or mayor of Hass tonight or
maybe wasn't the man who would later be
known as count Victor Lustig was born
Robert V Miller in Hostin a in a family
that he described as the poorest peasant
people and he was raised in a house made
of stone was little more than a cave or
was he the man who would be known as
Victor Lustig Robert Miller and more
than 40 other aliases was born sometime
in 1890 somewhere near the border
between Bohemia and Poland from two
parents who we can safely guess were a
girl and a guy but anything more than
that I wouldn't bet any money on it
relying on any of these stories would
imply it trusting the words of he who
would grow up to be the king of the
swindlers the Archduke of grifters the
CEO of confidence tricks incorporated on
one detail we can all agree he was a
bohemian in both meanings of the word he
definitely came from the land of Bohemia
and he led a lifestyle that could be
also described as both
at least according to the handy oxford
english dictionary which reads a
socially unconventional person
especially one who is involved in the
arts and what was the capital of the
bohemian lifestyle if not paris at the
height of the Belle époque and that's
exactly where we're going to pick up
again the story of our protagonist whom
I'm going to call Victor from now on
very little is known of Victor's
childhood and his early teens but we
know with a certain degree of confidence
that he lived in Paris around 1908 in
1909 he may have lived there to attend
University which backs up the version
that he came from a middle-class
backgrounds but apparently he spent
little time studying being more suited
to a life of gambling or womanizing and
generally having a lot of fun not
everybody agreed with his idea of fun
there especially when it involved
sleeping with somebody else's
girlfriends when Victor was 19 he was
scarred on his left cheek by the jealous
lover of his girl a scarf that would
remain visible for the rest of his life
Victor's bohemian lifestyle left other
durable marks on him albeit more
metaphorical ones during his formative
years Victor became proficient in
several languages including English
French and Italian more importantly was
starting to perfect his money-making
skills on the wrong side of the law
starting as entry-level as a pickpocket
Victor soon graduated to burglary and
then branched out into Street hustling
and finally earned a master's degree in
scamming and confidence tricks
especially contracts according to a true
crime magazine of his time by his late
teens Lustig
could make a deck of cards do everything
but talk
[Music]
[Applause]
after clearing the pockets of many a
Parisian Viktor moved to a new level of
con man ship being a con man aboard a
cruise ship between 1909 and the
outbreak of World War one Viktor
traveled back and forth across the
Atlantic from France to New York and
back picking his marks in other words
his victims among the nouveau riche
traveling in first-class it was in this
period that he created his most famous
persona the count Victor Lustig a
nobleman from the fallen kingdom of
Bohemia he acquired a set of well
tailored clothes and affected his
mannerisms to appear wealthy aristocracy
but never boastful nor arrogance and
most of all he looked worthy of
confidence despite being in his early
20s he managed to convince his Marx that
he was a broadway producer in search of
investors to put on a dazzling new
musical show this evolution into a
smooth the style of swindling did not
happen by magic
Victor needed a master and he found one
during one of these Atlantic trips in
Nicky Arnstein an American professional
gambler and con artist famous for being
the husband of actress Fanny Brice Nicky
and Fanny are now remembered as the main
characters of the film's funny girl and
funny lady with Barbara Streisand
Lustig would acknowledge Johnston as the
one who taught him the art of the corn
the one who raised him from the status
of promising rookie to smooth scam
master general Vance Dean's teachings
would influence the 10 golden rules of
the con which Victor formalized later in
his life if you're curious what those
golden rules might be well I'll give you
two for the moments the rest will be
coming later number one be a patient
listener it is this not fast talking
that gets a conman his cooze number two
never be bored in this spirit I will ask
you to continue to listen patiently and
try not to look too bored at this video
let's continue with plastics life for
the moment
when World War one broke out
transatlantic travel for the rich became
less frequent ins much more dangerous in
a way the u-boats were actually
responsible for the next stage in
Lustig's career the con artist II
settled in the US
mainly in Kansas City as ever the
details of his life in this period are
sketchy and unreliable but we do know of
some juicy bits during and immediately
after the war Victor partnered with a
sidekick known as Dapper Dan Collins
whom the New York Times described as a
former circus lion tamer and
death-defying bicycle rider
and with that I think it's fair to say
we love him already smooth Victor and
dapper Dan's main scam was called the
Romanian money box this was an ordinary
box fashioned to looked like complicated
machine with rollers and dials if you
put a banknote inside it say a $100 bill
and then inserted some chemicals the
machine would take six hours to print an
identical copy of your money that was so
realistic in a bank teller could
identify it as counterfeit after 12
hours of recovery time the Romanian box
was ready to print another bill the
trick behind it was elaborate but
brilliant
step 1 collect a handful of
hundred-dollar bills from your bank
ensuring their serial numbers are all
sequential step to alter the banknote so
they all have the same serial number
step 3
keep one note for demonstration purposes
and then stuff the other notes into the
machine then find your marks and get
them interested in the machine now
demonstrate how the Romanian box works
spend these six hours of time waiting
with your marks while you Wine and Dine
them step 6 open the box and voila there
are now two banknotes pretty cool and
your money has doubled next steps to
further convince the marks take them to
a bank and deposit the freshly printed
bill watch them gasp with amazement when
the bank teller fails to realize it's
fake money final step sell the Iranian
box to your mark for anything up to ten
thousand dollars saying that it will
repay itself very quickly while the
marks waited for the 12 hours for the
machine do rest before they used it
again Lustig and Collins would skip town
ready to trick somebody else the genius
part of this con was that nobody would
report it as a scam because that would
mean they were having to confess to
counterfeiting a similar scam in the
sense that it exploited the victims
dishonest leanings took place
in Montreal in the 1920s here Victor
gained the trust of a wealthy banker
named Linus Merton he first had his
wallet stolen and then he returned it
intact he then lured him into a gambling
scheme Victor said that his cousin amel
perhaps dapper dan was able to delay by
one minute the Telegraph was relaying
the results of horse races this vital
minutes would allow Victor a nurse and
to always place winning bets
Lustig convinced the banker to place a
bet for a whopping a thirty thousand
dollars no surprises here the lustick
cousins very quickly disappeared from
Canada again they left behind a victim
who was too ashamed and too guilty of
bet fixing to go to the police
the next big job it took place in 1922
in Missouri under the name of Robert
Duvall he offered to the American
Savings Bank thirty two thousand dollars
in World War one bonds the famous
Liberty Bonds in exchange for ten
thousand dollars in cash and some
farmlands at the moments of closing the
deal he switched the envelope containing
the bonds with an empty one with this
simple sleight-of-hand trick he walked
out with the bonds the farm and the cash
American Savings had some private
detectives who succeeded in tracking
lost ink to Kansas City but Victor could
rely on his ultimate weapon
smooth-talking he convinced the
detectives that if the bank pressed
charges and the story went public then
clients would lose confidence in them
this would spell ruin for American
savings so not only did he convince the
bank to drop all charges they even paid
him an extra thousand dollars to buy his
silence now you probably don't have to
worry about smooth talking con men in
your day-to-day life but you know even
if you do you still face risks from
modern-day con men those are cyber
criminals looking to nab your data steal
your identity and ruin your financial
standing con men they just basically got
smarter Tekken's now it's a work from
home job they are lazy and that's why
before we get into the biggest con today
I want to tell you about noir to VPN if
you're buying things online and using a
public Wi-Fi spot coffee shops airports
etc you really must be using a VPN and
that's where north VPN comes in I know
it's tempting not to bother and just
kinda hope for the best but really those
stories you read about online about
people having their identity stolen and
their financial standing ruins they are
real things that do happen to people
whenever I'm on public Wi-Fi
I always just turn my VPN on Andras
leave it on and then I don't have to
worry about anyone stealing my data but
it's not all about security you can also
use it to change the country that you
appear to be and so you can get content
that might normally be only available in
specific geographic locations nor VPN is
super fast so watching a video is a
breeze there's no lag whatsoever if
you've ever used VPNs and thought they
were slow well no more with Nord VPN and
you could use it on all of your devices
very very easily Android Chrome Windows
Linux and on six different devices at
the same time with just one account
there are also no logs kept at all
unlike companies based in Europe or the
u.s. not VPN is based in Panama so they
don't have to keep logs at all this is
excellent for your privacy indeed they
are the only VPN to get a perfect score
from PC Mag so start protecting your
internet experience today at North VPN
comm /by our graphics use the code
biographic stew get 75% off a three-year
plan and a month for free let's crack on
with today's video shall we the run-in
with the private detectives was not the
first time that Victor Lustig had risked
ending up behind bars in fact had been
arrested around 40 times but every time
he managed to talk or bribe himself out
of the sticky situation in extreme cases
he simply had his wife bail him out and
then he would disappear again Victor's
wife was called roberta norris a pretty
young redhead kanzen woman who he had
married on the 3rd of november 1919 but
more on Victor's private life in a bit
for now let's stick to talking shop in
May of 1925 Victor and dapper dan moved
to Paris possibly to escape increased
attention from American law enforcement
in Paris they read an article about the
status of disrepair of the Eiffel Tower
and how maintenance expenses would be
too costly for local governments that
sparked the idea for Victor's craziest
scam he would sell the Eiffel Tower the
idea was actually not that crazy the
tower had been erected in 1889 as a
temporary structure to be taken down no
later than 1909 and yet it was still
standing it was expensive to maintain
and the public opinion was split about
as many considering its a bit of an
eyesore so how about the French
government just decided to sell it as
scrap metal
Lustig carefully prepared his con he
first forged a set of stationery for the
ministry in charge of posts and
Telegraph's
this was realistic as the towers used as
a giant post to transmit radio signals
he then used the letter to summon the
five largest scrap metal dealers in
Paris they were invited to an exclusive
meeting at the hotel to Creon here was
the deal the French government was
considering tearing down the Eiffel
Tower and selling its pieces and scrap
metal listing insisted that the five
dealers kept quiet about it as the
government did not want it to leak to
the press at the meeting Victor
identified the fish that he was going to
catch the conveniently named Andre
Poisson his business was relatively
small compared to the others and because
of that was low in self-esteem
Lustig arranged a separate meeting with
pasa and expressing sympathy for his
budding business offered the deal to him
in exchange for a sizeable kickback it
was thus that countered Victor Lustig
not only sold the Eiffel Tower as a heap
of scrap metal but he also pocketed a
nice bribe on the side the next day
Victor and Dan left for Vienna and
waited patiently for the storm to calm
down their surprise there the French
newspapers they didn't report the scam
must incorrectly assumes that Poisson
had been too embarrassed to depress
charges it was all really just too good
to be true so what did he do next well
he returned to Paris and attempted the
exact same scam a second time with
different metal dealers of course but
this time around one of the dealers was
immediately suspicious and reported this
self-described ministry official to the
police Victor was quick to flee using
one of his many aliases he forged
passports and embarked again returning
to America
[Music]
upon returning to the u.s. Lustig set to
work again he barely got a kick out of
performing his confidence tricks but he
also needed to fund a very expensive
lifestyle he and his wife Roberta had a
daughter Betty Jean and their living
arrangements were very costly Roberta
and Betty Jean moved constantly from
town to town living in hotels
this was Lustig's idea to keep them
secret and avoid that they could be
traced back to him to prevent their
capture to make up for this
unconventional lifestyle Victor lavished
them with gifts when the girl reach
school age he signed her up for an
expensive Catholic boarding school in
Pittsburgh run by an order of nuns I
guess he was looking for a better moral
example than himself on top of this lots
to get to look after his second
unofficial wife or rather his long-term
mistress Billie may Schaible a notorious
brothel madam the long-suffering Roberta
was patient enough to put up with
basically being just a courier for bail
money but she could not tolerate her
husband's affair with Billie May nor the
additional philandering on the side so
she ultimately divorced him there's a
heartwarming reunion in which Roberta
literally tried to kill him by running
him over with her car but he was quick
on the dodge and apparently that was
enough for them to reconcile Victor and
Roberta they remarried because Lustig
had to do everything twice apparently
and unsurprisingly they later divorced
after Roberta found out that Victor was
lodging Billie May in the same hotel as
hers while Lustig was not working his
charms with the ladies he was always
looking for new tricks he probably
thought that scamming Schmucks was a bit
too easy so he set onto scamming
Chicago's most dangerous residents Al
Capone the plan was basic busted
convinced Capone to loan him $50,000 to
buy some stock that would guarantee a
sure profit he then deposited the cash
in a bank and just waited after some
weeks Victor returned to Capone and told
him that the stocks had crashed and the
money what it was gone but to apologize
he would return the 50 grand to the
gangster from his own pocket Capone did
not realize that lasting was essentially
just returning him his own money and he
gave him $5,000 for his honesty
Victor's next money-making scheme was
literally about making money in the
early 1930s at the height of the Great
Depression Victor got into
counterfeiting with two new accomplices
a chemist named Tom Shaw and an engraver
called William watts they were so
successful that they managed to produce
and circulate over 1 million dollars
worth of fake money the Treasury was so
concerned that there was a genuine worry
that this would imbalance the US economy
this was one step too far and it got the
attention of the Secret Service in one
agent in particular italian-american
Peter rebar know this is sort of ironic
because ribanna
means they steal in Italian for our
friends who are not familiar with US law
enforcement let me clarify one thing
today the Secret Service is associated
with the personal protection of the
president's and other high-ranking
officials its original task however was
and still is to track down and arrest
counterfeiters there was only after
President McKinley's assassination that
the Secret Service was assigned to
protect the president's because at the
time they were the only agency with
federal jurisdiction and how about a fun
fact if you know Secret Service
personnel introduce themselves they say
hello I am a secret agents which kind of
defeats the purpose secret agent Roy
Bono was able to trace back the
counterfeit money to a conman with a
number of aliases who had been selling
some mysterious money-making boxes this
had happens when the stick had sold a
Romanian box to a Texan sheriff when the
lawman had confronted him about the hoax
Victor had appeased him with a bribe in
fake cash Rabanne Oh in the Secret
Service established a connection between
the counterfeiters and the money box man
but they could not pin down lustick by
now they had taken to traveling with a
trunk full of disguises including a
rabbi priest and bellhop finally in 1935
ribanna received an anonymous tip-off
from a jealous mistress of plastic maybe
Billy may may be one of his many other
girlfriends
the agents converged on a hotel in New
York County Victor Robb eart Lustig
Miller was handcuffed just outside of
the hotel the secret agents found a key
in his pocket which turned out to be for
a locker in the Times Square subway
station inside they found stashes of
plates and chemicals used by his gangs
print money ad admiring agent told
Victor that he must be the smoothest con
man in the world but Victor just shook
his head and said I wouldn't say that
after all
you have conned me Lustig was put behind
bars in New York awaiting trial but he
had another trick up his sleeve he soon
realized that nobody was keeping count
of the bedsheets distributed to inmates
so little by little he stashed enough
bedsheets to fashion a rope on the 1st
of September 1935 he cut through the
wires in the washroom window and swung
to safety like a bohemian Tarzan to
distract on lookers he pulled a rag from
his pockets and pretended to clean the
jail's windows then where the final
jumpy landed on the pavements bowed to
his audience of passers-by and
disappeared into the night
Lustig did not evade the police for very
long though he had for a period in his
daughter's boarding school in Pittsburgh
until the 28th of September when FBI
agents GK Firestone and Secret Service
agent Fred Gruber spotted him ducking in
a car driven by a chauffeur
the two feds lept into their car and
they gave chase engines roared and they
were neck and neck for nine blocks
the agents yelled to the runways to
start but Lustig's driver would keep on
accelerating the agents had no choice
they jerked the steering wheel sideways
and rammed their car into victors
because crashed to a halt the agent's
pulled out their guns we like to imagine
that they said stick them up Lustig but
we do know that Victor told his captives
well boys
Here I am in November of 1935 Victor
Lustig was tried and sentenced to 20
years in prison
not just any prison though was Alcatraz
for the following years the man of many
aliases was simply known as convict
number 300 amongst other celebrities who
shared the Alcatraz facilities with him
there was none other than his former
mark Al Capone by now a syphilitic
shadow of his former self after many
years in the prison known as the rock
Victor's health declined by the 7th of
December 1946 he had filed 1192 medical
requests most of which were ignored as
the wardens thought they were a part of
some escape plan eventually Lustig was
transferred to a secure Hospital in
Missouri where doctors realized too late
that he was not faking there in a town
called Springfield the con man known as
count Victor Lustig died of pneumonia on
the 11th of March 1947 his death
certificate stated as occupation
apprentice salesman many years later in
March of 2015 check historian Tomas and
yell from listings hometown of Hostin a
set house to search for records and
evidence to clarify the mystery affect
his identity and browse through
historical documents
electoral rolls and even school
registers eventually he had to admit
defeat
that wasn't there any evidence that
Lustig was ever born he may not have
left us a clear answer on his identity
but Victor Lustig did leave us with a
clear set of rules on how to pull off
the perfect con and here they are number
one be a patient listener it is this not
fast-talking the gaps a con man is coos
number two never looked bored three wait
for the other person do you reveal any
political opinions then agree with them
for let the person reveal religious
views and then have the same wines
number five hint at sex talk but don't
follow it up unless the other fellow
shows a strong interest number six never
discuss illness unless some special
concern is shown number seven never pry
into a person's personal circumstances
they'll tell you all eventually number
eight never boast just let your
importance be quietly obvious number
nine never be untidy number ten never
get drunk now we're biographic we don't
endorse this advice to swindle scam or
bamboozle your fellow human beings
however we must admit that these are
pretty good pieces of advice when it
comes to engaging with someone and
creating a meaningful connection after
all these rules could apply to a
successful first date or a job interview
except for number five don't him that
sex talk when you're at a job interview
it's not gonna go well and maybe that's
the key to Victor Lustig illegal but
incredible successes not the elaborate
Romanian boxes not the sight of hands
and not even the counterfeiting skills
but simply his ability to connect with
others charm them and make them feel
important before robbing them blinds so
thank you for saying to the end of the
video I'll just ask you now if you'd
like to like this video share it
subscribe that would be great also do
you think we should give Victor Lustig a
movie let me know in the comments I kind
of imagined an earlier version of catch
me if you can it would be pretty cool
also please do check out nord VPN just
go to nord VPN comm /ba graphics for
that special deal there's also a link
below and thanks for watching
you